let's get when you try guys to properly
get immersed into Korean culture we're
gonna be attending Kate cotton North
America's largest kpop convention and
music festival all right Sonny kpop make
up takes between three and six hours we
got 20 minutes okay beautiful you guys
I wear polo shirts all the time I've
never changed this haircut I'm excited I
like getting makeup put on it's sort of
like a mini face massage I think it's
kind of relaxing I think I look a little
more Korean than the other try guys
that's racist I've been saying for years
that I am the prettiest try guy today's
my chance to prove it I've been saying
for years the Korean the ocean of beauty
I think is a little different than say
what we have here in the West beauty is
not something that you're born with it's
something that you cultivate are you
making me paler
that's not possible what's an
interesting challenge for us is that I
have a monolid which means that I don't
have the crease so I makeup is
completely doable with circa face
certain body type but the notion is that
you can always improve it you're really
jamming I didn't get so relaxed when I
get my cap put on I'm a canvas
k-pop stars do this for hours it hurts
my eyes so much and when I was growing
up in high school like no one liked
Korean stuff no one you've known you'll
okay do they have American Con in Korea
no beauty's a process not everyone's
born as beautiful as me so you just you
have to work at it if you know for
pension and using the right product so
going to the right here so long you can
get the right loop without all my
imperfections I look beautiful I've
always said I got little eyes but I'm
proud of them so all you small light
Asians out there don't let anyone tell
you that you aren't pretty cuz you don't
got big ol eyes like keel and paint
five-phase make me look like another
race I wonder if my wife does makeup
like this you're right she does wheezing
Korean society is full beauty conscious
or body conscious it's not because
people are superficial but I think it's
because it's a really competitive
society okay so much what I have to pay
you to sabotage your team's makeup you
give me the CL signature beauty mark I
know what everybody's freaking out about
just a little paint on your face girl
scale of one to ten how bad you want to
bang me right now there we go oh yeah I
just look like talked to my grandma okay
I look just
sensual passionate like Perella Deville
well good job you did look up Kenai
among two different people Keith and
Kevin yeah I just cover my face like
this that is CL dies you did a great job
thank you so much sunny before
transforming us into k-pop stars we have
to go to a photo shoot now I am here
with the beautiful
Irene Kim you are a model Wow I pose and
walk in a straight line for Lily you're
gonna be helping us with is posing for
photo shoots and how we should pose and
inhabit those k-pop stars
very cool and kill so chill just like
just no that's like awkward what's a
very amber pose so much going on right
now my model am I gonna be like one way
this way and another way this way this
is Keith this is Kevin
[Music]
I'm a big fan keep oppa like the cute
sexy look cute and sexy the hardest line
to tread I know nothing there I'm gonna
doing it she does like the head so
there's like the to think like that's
rapsa you're going rap bro calm down be
sexy yes that's really good
so Tiffany I would describe her as very
cute sweet and angelic would you say
that I'm the cutest of the four of us
you can say it it's okay this is the
safe place Kauai is only is that only
Japan cultures collide disquiet transfer
surprised look was like a happy surprise
[Music]
I think something a little bit more
moody chic and sexy base of being a kpop
star
and how would you suggest posing if I
was there in a photo shoot with you as
CEO CEO is very like badass like the bad
girl
it's more on the eye you're the queen of
kpop right now
kind of creates a new perspective on how
we look at kpop Korea itself the nation
itself is turning into a friend like my
transformation that yeah take that Zack
I don't know I think we're dying